-Oh, my goodness. Come on.
Partner!
-Hi.
-My part-- My partner.
-Blueberry.
-Blueberry muffin all the way.
I can't believe we got that.
That's bizarre.
-I feet really good about it.
-I feel really, really good
about it.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for being in studio,
by the way.
It means a lot to our audience
and to me and the band.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You live in New York City.
You've lived here for
10 years now.
-I -- Mm-hmm.
I moved here
when I was 16, yeah.
-So you're a New Yorker.
-I don't want to, like,
adopt that without, like,
having permission
to say that, you know?
-I mean, you live in --
-I certainly love
the city so much,
but I feel like
there's a lot about me
that says that
I'm not from here.
-You live in a studio apartment,
which is very New York.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, I think it's one person.
-Thanks.
That's what you normally hear
in a studio apartment --
one person like, "Yeah!"
You -- But you recently
got furniture.
-It's taken 10 years,
but I finally buckled down
and I bought some furniture.
For a very long time,
I've had a mattress on the floor
and a light from IKEA.
-Uh-huh.
-And then I just felt like
maybe that --
It wasn't a good look
for me anymore,
and I thought I should grow up.
-It's not --
Yeah, I mean, after a while,
yeah, if you can afford it,
furniture is fantastic.
Yeah, it's great.
-Oh! I will say, if you have
a mattress on the floor
for a very long time
and then you upgrade
to having a bed frame,
the process of getting
in and out of bed becomes
significantly easier.
It's less of, like,
a, like "Huh!"
and more of just like a,
"I'm getting out of bed now."
-Yeah, that's correct. Yes.
You don't have to like, "Hwah!"
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, now it's a whole thing.
-It's just like
I casually get out of bed
and I just go about
my whole day.
-It's better for you with the
higher up, yeah.
This is your setup
in your house.
You took a picture of you
having breakfast.
This is what it looks like
in your apartment.
-I love breakfast.
-Yeah, me too.
That's unbelievable.
That's your whole setup.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah. So, you have your eggs.
-Yeah, if you scroll in,
though, like,
some really well-made eggs.
-That's not how
a photo works, Margaret.
You can't -- you can't zoom in.
You can't zoom in to any photo
and make it zoom in.
But, alright, you have
eggs and toast, I see,
and maybe an avocado, perhaps?
-Yes.
-Oh, that's what I would have.
-Come over for
breakfast sometime.
I have a table now!
-I'll bring a pillow.
-Yeah.
-Perfect.
I do love that, though.
It's kind of cool
that's what you did.
-Thank you.
-And now --
-You're the only one
that thinks that.
-Yeah.
But now you have...
-Furniture.
-...furniture.
So you have a bed.
Do you have a table?
-Bed, table, lamps...
-Yeah, you name it. Lamps.
-...chairs, sofa.
-It's like we're playing
"Password" again.
Furniture!
-Furniture!
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Dinging ]
Thank you.
We got the password.
I want to
talk to you about "Maid."
It's M-A-I-D, by the way,
if you're listening and don't --
because it could be,
"Oh, it's called 'Made,'"
and they don't find it.
-Mm-hmm.
-M-A-I-D.
This is based on a true story,
a memoir.
-It certainly is.
-Yeah.
-I've said "certainly"
three times now.
-Yeah, certainly -- Why?
-I'm nervous, Jimmy.
I'm really nervous.
-Don't be nervous.
You're winning so hard.
You have no idea
how much you're winning.
-Okay, here we are.
"Maid," with an "I."
-"Maid."
Your mom is Andie MacDowell,
who I love.
-Me too.
-Yeah.
Well, of course you love mom.
She's acting with you.
-I already said,
"I love you, Dad,"
and now, I feel like I should
say, "I love you, Mom."
Yes, she's acting with me.
-Yeah.
I love you, mom, too, yeah.
And dad.
I love your dad, too.
-He's great.
-Yeah, I don't know him,
but I'm assuming.
-You'd love him.
-I would, right?
-Mm-hmm. You would.
Certainly.
-Certainly.
And now -- He probably has,
like, you know, lamp, tables.
-Actually, no.
I -- He doesn't.
-Your dad
doesn't have furniture?
-He doesn't have
any of those things.
No, I'm serious.
-Wait. What?
So your dad doesn't have --
-We're taking a real detour,
but, no, he has no furniture.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. What is going --
What are you talking about?
-He lives in Panama,
on a construction site.
He has no furniture.
But, okay,
back to the point -- "Maid."
M-A-I-D.
-Wow! Okay. Sorry.
This is so interesting.
-My mom is in there.
-Yes, your mom's in there.
Yeah, yeah.
-The show.
-The show. Alright,
let's talk about the show.
It's on Netflix.
-Uh-huh.
-Okay, yeah, do you want to tell
everyone who you play?
-I do. I play Alex.
-Yeah.
-She is a young mother
who is trying to get out of a --
This is serious.
She's trying to get out of an
emotionally abusive relationship
and she has a child.
And she's trying to
escape poverty
and she starts cleaning homes
to take care of her kid.
And it's about that.
-Yeah.
You're getting
great reviews for this.
-And she has furniture.
-Yeah, there's furniture.
No spoilers, Margaret.
No spoilers,
-Actually, no, she doesn't
have furniture either.
None of us have furniture.
-Yeah, it's interesting. Yeah.
No, yeah, no spoilers.
None of us have furniture.
-Okay.
-I can't believe your dad
doesn't have furniture.
That's interesting.
-None.
-He's in Panama, you said?
-He is.
-Wow! That's so interesting.
On a construction site.
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm really interested in
your dad.
-I'll tell you
all about him later.
-Yeah, we can hear about it
later, 'cause we're gonna be --
-He specifically said,
"Hey, Margaret,
don't talk about me tonight."
-You did.
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
-And we spent most of
the interview
talking about your dad.
-Yeah.
-Wow. He just sounds
fascinating to me.
-I love him so much.
-Yeah, I love him, too.
I mean, again,
I don't know him, but...
He's involved with you somehow,
I got to root for that person.
-Okay. Thanks.
-For those people.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I think we should be pals.
We should be friends.
-I want to be your friend.
Ever since you
said that thing outside,
I've been trying to
orchestrate a friendship here.
-Yeah. I can see us,
like, you know,
getting together and playing,
like, a game night or something.
-I love games.
-Right?
Yeah.
-So much.
-Yeah. What do you...
But you don't
own any games, right?
So people have to bring it
over to your house.
-Yeah. Or, you know, you come up
with the games yourself.
Like, "What are you thinking
right now?"
That's what
they were saying that
we should be practicing, right?
-Yeah.
You want to play that game?
-Alright, what are you
thinking about right now?
Your dad.
-He did it.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
[ Ding ]
See? I'm really good at this.
You're fantastic in this show,
and I want to show a clip.
Here is Margaret Qualley
in "Maid."
Take a look at this.
-Are you drunk?
-I'm working on it.
-And you've been out
all day biking.
-So?
-So Maddy has just been
stuck with your mom,
sitting on the couch,
watching "Jeopardy!"?
-No, no, no.
They -- they watch
"Wheel of Fortune."
-Oh, this is funny to you?
What if she got sick?
-Okay...
-What if she got hurt?
What if she needed to
go to the E.R.?
-My mom would take her.
-Your mom?
-Yes.
Your mom that spent half of your
childhood addicted to Oxy?
-Will you chill?
-I'm not going to chill, Sean.
You have a rage problem.
-I don't know how you even say
it with a straight face.
-You have a rage problem
and you have a drinking problem
and you shouldn't have
custody of our kid
if you're going to
let your mommy do it for you.
-Margaret Qualley, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]